is an executive session which prior to
going into that i'm going to read the
chairman script
i'm sure you all becoming very familiar
with that
as well as i so i'll start as chair of
the house education committee i find
that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
the covet 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67 and
the governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public executive hearing or
executive session
of bills referred to the education
committee
executive session on pending legislation
may
be held please note that there is no
physical location for members of the
public to observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting however in accordance with the
emergency order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
and the public has taxes to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform or by
california
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice of this meeting complies with
house rules rsa 91-8
anyone who has a problem accessing the
271-3600
or email hcs at ledge.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned
and rescheduled i want to introduce the
staff at a meeting
that are on the meeting assisting us
today jennifer ford
committee researcher please know that
note that all votes that are taken
during this meeting shall be done by roe
paul vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance when each member states
their presence please
also state whether there is anyone in
the room with you during this meeting
good morning everyone representative
cordelli
you're in the committee room
representative bowman
representative allen in the committee
room representative lacus
here in the committee room
representative moffat in the house
representative uh notter
here in the community room and for dave
hopps
representative
here home alone in salisbury
representative ford here home alone
in chester thank you sir
representative william here in the
representative miler here in my office
in cantuc new hampshire by myself
representative luno reporting from
hopkinton
representative shaw here in the
committee room representative cornell
here in manchester alone representative
tanner
here in sunapee new hampshire georges
mills the suburbs
uh in my office alone with my rescue dog
raven
representative allison uh president i am
home alone in concord
representative mullen here in the bunker
represent and play i am home
alone in jaffrey new hampshire
representative woodcock here in santa
clara new hampshire
with my barking dog and my wife
eventually
represented lab thank you very much i'm
here
in haverhill not naval new hampshire
here in
the legislative office building in
concord
all present thank you very much
representative tanner i want to see
raymond
even raven is a very shy dog i got her
from the rescue
and she's probably the most fearful dog
i've ever had but she's non-aggressive
so she's
she's coming along we've had her for six
months and um
there's still rooms in the house she
won't go in so
but she's made tremendous progress so
she's a great dog
that's wonderful one of these days we're
going to have to have the background of
all
our speed behind each individual
with ozzy
and all the other animals exactly and
scotty
and and we will identify each other by
the breed of dog which they
own or that's a the family member these
are all family members
so i thank you all very much today
on the docket we have uh consecuting
going on
we are going to be executing hb 608 hp
20 and then going down to what we
originally had set forward
just several spills guys i spoke with uh
there are several that we will not be
discussing today
uh we will be looking at hp 320 that
specifics testing bill
we will be looking at hp 110 which is
distribution of adequacy grants
we will be looking at hb 442 relative to
penalties for failure to report to the
doe
um those are the three bills which i'd
like to get through
this today um other bills
um uh i i think have some questions or
concerns that we've had from hearings
and there's probably
need for some uh amending language and
the amending language and all some of
those bills have that written but ols
has been so far behind we just don't
have that stuff back yet
or i haven't even submitted it so um
we won't be discussing the other videos
that are listed for today
so just so you're aware of that if we
handle this right we may be able to get
out by noon
which is a challenge but perhaps that be
welcomed by all the stores so that with
that i'd like to get right into
the bills that we went through just now
i'd like to
open up with hb 608 and i'll
emotions
okay i move that we retain six zero
eight
is there a second for retention about hb
608 represent leia
high second and representative uh
seconds that motion
so we have the floor to retain
hb608 that's a funding bill
an early bill uh representative does you
have any discussions
yes um going through
the way the monies are and everything
right now we have
way too many towns who are the ones who
most need the money
and they're losing money and towns who
we need the money
are gaining a bunch of money and so the
numbers are obviously not
not right um trying to get amendments in
a timely manner with covid
is very difficult and we're basically
out of time the bill's not ready
thank you very much uh does the second
cure to add anything
um thank you mr chair i agree that we do
need to have the time to make sure these
formulas are correct
and i appreciate that we're moving to
attend this thank you could you all hear
that out there
okay thank you so is there any
discussion
from the committee representative thank
you very much mr chair
i'll agree that the need-based approach
for school funding um would be important
and i'll support the motion
with but but also i'd like the
opportunity down the road as this bill
gets worked on to work with you
uh mr chair on it i i've also indicated
to represent milo or at least just last
night we discussed it a little bit
uh we're going to try and find that time
where we can have a report provided to
this committee
so uh we're going to slip that in as
soon as possible
and i'll be working with with uh perhaps
a miler
to try and get that set up
not seeing any uh we will go ahead and
call that motion
clerk are you ready yes motion to retain
hdl uh yeah each bill house bill
608 fna local
representative cardelli yes
representative bone yes
representative howard yes representative
yes representative moffat yes
representative notter
yes representative andres yes
represent ford yes represent lyon
yes representative yes representative
miller
yes president yes
representative shaw yes representative
cornell
yes represent tanner yes
yes represent yes
representative woodcar yeah yes yes
sorry
representative oh yes yes i was
thank you very much so hb 608
has been retained and we will look at
that within the committee
i'd like to now move on to h 20 and i'm
going to hand the gavel over to
representative cordelli mr chairman
would like to um recognize chairman for
a motion
thank you very much i would like to
recommend on hb20
retention
you have a second second uh represent
seconds
yes again uh we had a
good discussion on uh hb 20 yesterday
by uh all committee members uh i'm
always been and i will continue to be an
advocate for
education choice and opportunity for
children and i believe the intent
and the direction that hb20 is going is
needed throughout the state i believe
there's many
policy considerations that have gone
into that
uh and a lot of hard work however i
i believe that there is still room for
us to further discuss
and clarify uh some of the issues that
may have been brought up yesterday
so with that i have passed that this
bill be retained
thank you mr chairman uh president do
you
have any comments uh yes thank you uh mr
chairman i i would just like to
add that the bill
of this significance needs to be right
and the lines in this committee uh
aren't the folks to do that so
i think this is this is a good move to
pause reflect and
okay well can you hear me yes i can
thank you thank you
uh first of all i i want to uh thank
uh chairman ladd for yesterday
we had a deep discussion
with which we were able to pose our
questions
and attempt to get some answers to some
very serious questions
and i would concur with uh
representative allard
that this is probably i believe this is
the most significant bill
in the nine years that i've been on this
committee
and i want to uh i'm going to support
the retention of this bill
because i do think that it represents a
recognition
that this bill is not ready yet based
upon the concerns that we've ex
that we've uncovered yesterday
so i want to thank the chairman for
yesterday's hearing
and i want to thank him for the
retention of this bill
at this point in time this does not mean
that i support this bill
but i do support the issue of retaining
the bill
and uh so for further work can take
place on it
thank you very much thank you mr our
representative
are there further representative cornell
i see your hand up
i just i don't know if i would ever
support this bill but i'm glad that it's
being retained and i would support that
because
i could never vote for something without
a fiscal note knowing how we'll
impact um the city of manchester
and our property taxes and what it will
do to our school so
fiscally i i would just need much more
information before being able to
to vote for this so thank you for
retaining it
thank you are there further questions
thank you susan
it represents shaw yes um i just
wanted to say that um i think that
eventually
um school
choice is going to be
a part of education and i think that
if it's going to be done and it's going
to be done correctly
we have to have bipartisan support
and it has to be proven that it's going
to be
beneficial to everyone to the taxpayers
to the parents to the children and
mostly
for the children and i think that this
is a great move that we're going to
retain it and look at it and work on it
and perhaps we will have a bipartisan
agreement
at some point and i think that that is
the only way
that this can be uh processed
uh properly and it's the only way that
the public
will be able to understand and to
realize
that something has to be done has to be
changed
and the way to do it is to do it
together and i appreciate that
thank you very much representative shaw
further
further questions i see rick's cornell
you still have your hand up is that
just didn't pull it down or you have
i i guess she's okay um
any further com i can't hear you on
patricia
you're probably not unmuted okay i got
you okay good
uh are there any other comments then
madam clerk thank you very much would
you please call the roll
yes this is fun hb 20
fna local representative cordelli
yes representative brought to retain
sorry uh representative glenn said yes
representative boehm
yes representative allard
representative lacus yes representative
office yes representative notter
yes representative andres yes
representative ford yes
representative land yes representative
sodi
yes representative luno
yes representative shaw yes
representative cornell yes alexander
tanner yes representative ellison
yes representative mellon yes
representative leg yes understand wood
clock
20-0 retention
thank you very much uh uh
with those two bills behind us now we're
going to be looking at what was
originally scheduled for
today and we'll look at those three
bills
um the first event which is a bill that
was put forth by
representative moffitt and was boxed by
a number of people
hb 320 which deals with uh civics
representative uh uh mob if you're
recognized for a motion
uh thank you mr chair i'd first like to
uh
motion make a motion of the amendment
that i sent out to everyone
a few days ago the amendment
simply ch representative lee and a
couple others
accurately noted that the new version of
the naturalization exam
has 228 questions rather than 100 so
we're just changing
in the amendment we would like to change
the number 100
to 128. so have you put forth that
question
that's my motion is to amend the uh
for our past well uh
making the motion of the amendment first
yes yes
yeah so you're putting forth so so we
have a
motion put forward by representative is
there a second
second yes thank you very much for
sending the shot a second
well representative representative shaw
she's a
co-sponsor that bill so obviously made
by representative moffitt second by
representative shaw
uh for the amendment uh uh
what's the amendment number uh
representative do you have that
i i do have that uh
somewhere here uh i got it
okay so the amendment is zero two seven
one
h simply
uh changes the number to the accurate
number that rate we have on that test
today
uh would you like to speak to your
promotion representative
point of order yes do we have copies of
that amendment
your email to the committee it came in
yeah it was in an email came out to you
it did all right i just didn't see it so
all right thank you basically changes
on the bottom says on the 100 question
is there a discussion on the amendment
not not seeing any further need for
discussion or comments from those
participating uh madam clerk would you
please call the roll
yes um representative fedele
yes this is on amendment
zero two seven one h representative
boehm
yes representative aller yes
representative
yes representative moffat yes
representative notter
yes representative andres yes
representative ford yes roxanne land
yes representative saudi yes
representative miler
representative shaw yes representative
cornell
yes representative tanner yes
president ellison yes representative
mullen
yes representative lay
yes represent woodcock no
represent vlad yes 18
okay so now we have the bill amended is
there
a call upon representative for a further
motion
uh without a unless there was a
request for me or someone to speak to
the
speak to the entire bill i would uh move
that we uh
adopt the bill as amended yes
there will be an opportunity for all to
speak to it uh when we get a second
second okay the second has been made by
representative shaw so
we have now 320 civics testing we have
a motion to approve the bill
as amended with zero two seven
uh famous joe uh very briefly i went
over
the merits of this initiative in the
hearing and i'll just simply say
uh it's uh it's not a a radical
measure at all many other states do this
type of thing
my sense is that the parents want it as
i said in committee
i think is someone who
favors publication public education that
supports public education
i think this is a nice step to help uh
improve confidence in public education
uh one other comment my friend dr kyle
radd who
you all know i don't know if dr ladd is
listening uh
you may have picked up that he
ironically was a civic student of mine
uh
many years ago i i was not his student
he used my students some
folks get those mixed up uh and after
introducing the bill i
was not able to speak and dr rad who i
think the world of
um he and his family from grofton
uh he did make a comment that he was
very comfortable that
the way that civics is being taught now
in
in the schools is is fine and uh
i think it is fine in some schools some
schools it is not
it's very uneven uh and the the
final comment i would simply make would
be uh if i would have been able to ask
dr ladd a question i would have
asked him about simply driver's licenses
you know every student
in school who takes driver ed has a
class
and at the end of the class before they
get their license they take a driver's
test
so i by the thinking of some they
wouldn't need the driver's test they're
fine just with the classes
well you see my point i think that with
something as important as civics
i think we should augment the the class
with
uh this wonderful assessment that uh
that naturalized citizens need to take
so uh that's all i have to say
on the uh on the donate i hope uh
you'll support it thank you very much
are there any comments from
the second no i agree with
representative market
representative tanner uh thank you mr
chair
i uh thoroughly agree with civics
education and with dr ladd that it's
being taught in our
our schools my concern with this bill
and and i don't mind uh students taking
this test uh i think it probably would
be
a good project within the civics
classes however it's set up in this bill
to be a high-stakes test
that they have to take it to graduate
which means that
those people that have a difficult time
those students that have a difficult
time
taking high stakes tests uh those who
have trouble with
certain learning disabilities will we
cry require
extra time extra effort um
extra money in the schools to do this so
it's
it's kind of an unfunded mandate that um
i'm very reluctant um to put this
burden on our public schools right now
so i will be voting against this bill
thank you
representative yes i just
want to amplify what representative
tanner said
taking the test is fine but not from a
high-stakes standpoint and that's what
this bill
uh proposes and i'm against that
kind of a proposition in order for
somebody to graduate from
high school thank you thank you
representative
thank you mr chairman um
i have a couple of points and i won't
reiterate although i do concur with
representative tanner and
milo this is a huge piece for a
youngster
saying the most important thing to
graduate basically is that you pass this
test with a c or a c minus at a 70.
um but the information that's contained
in this
examination is already prescribed
in our rsa in the pacific curriculum
each school is already required to have
a civics curriculum each school is
required to have each student take the
service curriculum
before they pass this is just adding a
additional requirement on local
communities
on how to establish their graduation uh
program requirements and that that by
itself
is is not a good thing uh we try to stay
away from telling local communities
what to put in their curriculums how to
evaluate teachers what they do the whole
piece
that's not our role so i would i would i
would
uh concur with representative moffett i
think is terrific
uh in terms of the intent it should be
be great to be
to augment any uh curriculum that we
have in civics but clearly not to be
passed or not pass from high school on
this exam
thank you mr chairman uh representative
[Music]
uh thank you very much uh mr chair yeah
i
i agree with um with
with what um uh representatives uh
tanner miler and woodcock have have said
on this
but uh but going further um you know i
was
i would be hopeful that uh that the
committee would consider retaining this
bill
particularly because of some information
we received
from from martha madison who's the
executive director of the new hampshire
institute
for civic education and i would say is
one of the
the leading advocates for civics
education
in the state and uh she and and
her organization have set up a round
table of it's a bipartisan nonpartisan
group that that involves some
some of their trustees including dan
feltus and chuck douglas
as well as representatives from the
department of education the new
hampshire bar
association the new hampshire historical
society superintendents principals
parents teachers and students
to uh to develop what it is
should be used to to assess some
curriculum
sorry civics competency in new hampshire
and they expect to have that work
completed
in october of this year and
and given that i think rather than
rushing in with
um with a federal naturalization
civics exam that is rapidly changing
right now in terms of um new questions
that are introduced and
and things that we um that we defer
to this um this bipartisan nonpartisan
roundtable
in terms of recommendation and and i
think uh you know i think retention is
probably the
better uh uh choice with um
with this bill right now thank you
representative
uh thank you mr chairman first i'd like
to say
civics in a lot of schools is not being
taught
you see the word civics and teach other
things
so without being taught next taking you
can see surveys on the street asking
people
one of the three four three levels of
government nobody knows
who's the vice president nobody knows so
there's a big problem
with civics being taught also
interesting one of the
when we heard it said that even though
she was against it
when she taught civics she used this
test
at the beginning of her course and the
test after the course
and but her argument was there wasn't
any time
in the curriculum to do it again when
she taught it the worst time
the also uh
yeah oh that's it thank you thank you
very much represent woodcock do you have
your hand up again here
i apologize chairman admiral thank you
take it down
okay thank you uh further further
comments
thank you mr chairman i am in favor of
this bill
as you know by looking at me i don't
have children in school
but i have many parents contact me
and parents are
don't like it because their children are
not being taught
what they need to be taught in schools
and i'm not saying this is in
every school the ones that are doing a
good job in civics
that's great but the ones that at we
need to bring them up to standard and
personally i think this bill will do it
and i back it
cornell i guess if it's supposed to be
being taught in the schools um which it
is it's one of the competencies and if
it's not being taught
isn't that the department of education
that's supposed to oversee that and make
sure that what's
supposed to be taught is being taught
and i know they're very busy and they
don't have the time to do that
but i don't think passing a bill saying
they must pass this test where teachers
might just take teach to the test
instead of students
learning civics they're going to
memorize the answers to a test
which they will forget in a month
because that's what we do when we have
to memorize something
and it doesn't relate to anything else
it's not taught it's memorizing
um i i don't think making them take the
test
i i think there should be more civics
that kids take you know
every day i realize things that i don't
know as an adult who
reads newspapers and and keeps up with
things and every day it's like
i didn't know that and so i i think
there's plenty that
students could be taught but i don't
think making
the this test part of their high school
graduation requirement will accomplish
that
you know but i think they should be the
schools should be responsible for
for teaching civics and someone should
be checking on that
that's all thank you very much uh rep
sound luna
thank you very much again mr chair um i
agree with everything
representative cornell just said um but
the reason i put my hand up
uh was was because i'm very concerned
particularly after what um
representative
baum and andrews said that that civics
um is not being taught in uh in a lot of
schools
and the effective date on um on
house bill 320 is 60 days after passage
so i'm i'm really not sure what the
schools
and the seniors are going to be
expected to do or or what people expect
to happen
um even this during this school year
if um uh if this if this passes uh
and and and is going to apply to
students in those districts where civics
education is currently not being taught
thank you very much um i i'd like to
recognize
uh representative scotty
i did a little experimentation
if your ten-year-old passive that uh
tells me that uh
you know it's it's not a high-stakes
test in the sense that it's uh
terribly demanding information is out
there
eighth graders some given
at the discretion of the school district
i do want to respond
represent tanner mentioned special needs
students the bill specifically
allows districts to administer the
assessment
to students with ieps in accordance with
the recommendations locally of the
district uh
and also uh representative luna would
mention martha madsen who
is as he stated is uh at the forefront
of civics education
here a very very long conversation with
her two days ago and she was
uh we had a wonderful conversation about
all aspects of civics education which
she supports i support
and uh we both agreed that assessments
are
important i don't know that i would say
she specifically
endorsed the spell i don't think i won't
i would go that far except to say
that we had a wonderful conversation she
acknowledges that assessment is very
important
in the in the big picture thank you
thank you very much yeah i haven't had a
chance to
chime in yet uh several years back uh
senator d'alessandro myself introduced
legislation which has become law
and identifies various themes that i've
been placed into
law topics regarding civics
and we also recognize that instruction
curriculum
is a responsibility of the local school
district so it's not up to doe to come
down
and give that assessment in fact when we
looked at the statewide assessment
several years back we looked at
mathematics and language and writing and
reading the other areas of assessment
are those
that are of the local community
so i think this is not a responsibility
of do
doe to ensure that this is being done
it's a responsibility a local school
district to ensure
if it hasn't been done then it belongs
down there
however we have before identified these
themes
and topics i see absolutely no problem
with our administering this assessment
especially if we know
a 10 year old is able to pass this and
do it i think every every person ought
to be able to pass it
and and to understand that the
this test identifies various principles
and beliefs that this country
yes go go ahead um on
just for my own notification on the
amendment i didn't see the
uh effective date although i do see it
on the primary bill of 60 days
um so i just want to clarification
uh from the protocol maybe
representative moffatt or you could
explain it to me
if a high school student has already
taken a civilized course
in their uh process right now that would
say a junior
or a senior and pass that course
does that mean we have to go back and
set up a separate
uh program to have them take that test
even though they've already passed
civics it's question a and question b
is uh is that effective date uh
would it i understand 60 days from
passage at least on the primary bill
does that mean that that would be
effective this year pastoral
that's two questions to respond to your
question
uh representative it says 60 days
following
this bill being you know approved or
signed into law
um upon passage and we're looking that
we're just concluding the month of
february so it's march april may
left in this school year very little of
june and so this bill has to float
through
our body on the floor go to the senate
same thing there
i doubt very seriously if it's going to
be signed into law
prior to june 30 of this year and that's
the end of this fiscal year
and the term for those students that are
seniors this year so i don't think it's
going to be relative to
to a senior having to pass this to
graduate this year
i just don't think that could you answer
what was your part two if i've already
if i've already taken the civics course
on high school and passed it
where something would there be a whole
special testing for this
representative you want to answer that
part uh
yeah thank you for your question uh as
representative vlad said
should this measure move forward the
60-day time thing would push it into the
next school year
and so uh current students who satisfied
local civics
requirements by taking a class would be
off would be all set to graduate this
year
if this measure goes into effect then
the districts would need to adapt to it
uh in 21 22.
so to follow up they have to if i've
already taken a class i'm
a sophomore or junior right now i pass
civics with an a
i'm done civics so i the school system
will have to set up in the future
some special testing about the process
well there was the the intent of this
is to have this assessment in place for
uh 2022
uh is a graduation requirement not not
not this year it's so bad
doesn't say that thank you thank you mr
chairman thank you representative
okay um representative thank you mr
chair
one point of clarification the amendment
only replaces child
paragraph one so the effective date
stays in place
so with this you know june going to may
if we're not definitely not going to be
passed out
april 30th so this would uh definitely
apply to the following school year
and if a student is a senior and already
had civics in high school i would assume
that just because you finish your civics
class
and you can now forget all this stuff i
think it'd be a great idea that they
be administered the civics desk before
they before they graduate
that shouldn't take a whole lot of time
i'd probably sit down and take it for 30
seconds or
30 minutes 30 minutes
um so uh representative mullen
uh thank you mr chair so i
could not agree with you more that i
believe that this is a local control
issue
uh there's nothing that prevents a
school system
from utilizing this exam as
part of their curriculum i i think i'm
correct in saying that
um but but i am somewhat
dismayed at our indicating that there
are schools all over the state
that are not teaching civics education
to the standard that they're supposed to
and then
reflecting back on the idea that
the department of education shouldn't
have authority over those schools to be
able to
go in and work with the school to make
sure that they're meeting the standards
that are
in fact set by the doe so
that concerns me and uh
moving forward from this point whether
it's the exam on civics education or not
i think we ought to be taking a look at
the claims that are made
against school systems that they are are
not doing something that they're
supposed to
and where the jurisdiction lies
on corrective action for those school
systems
thank you thank you further comments
yes represent thank you mr chair
should the should the bill be amended to
like something like
7122 something like that based upon this
conversation
uh i i don't believe so i think that you
know it's
uh i i don't think it's going to be
uh going in effect during this fiscal
year and so the following fiscal year
you'll be signed a law on the front side
of that and there's ample opportunity
for these schools to
get up and get going
so so excuse me so you believe that the
60 day after
is going to take place subsequent to
this school year
well it at the time frame for this to
to go through the senate and then be
signed into law
it's it's highly unlikely that it's
going to
you know be done before the at least the
that's my assumption though okay that's
that that's the concern of
that was just my concern the timeliness
of this and when it would take place
thank you
very much further further comments
yes representative thanks mr chair um
and and thanks for your time on on this
um do
what at what point do um
do school districts develop curriculum
and assessments
and even if this does roll into the the
fy
22 school year
do school districts have time to make
changes to curriculum and assessments
to do that particularly when when
you know students graduating that year
may be taking
civics well they might be taking civics
this year i think as representative
woodcock
said so i think the effective date is is
potentially a very
important element of this if we want to
yes representative yes
representative allard yes representative
lakes
yes representative moffat yes
representative notter yes representative
ambrose
yes representative ford yes
representative lyon yes representative
sodie
yes 15 miler no
representative luna no representative
shaw yes
representative cornell no representative
tanner
no is that ellison
no who's then in mullen no
is that leg no understanding woodcut
12-8 will there be a minority report yes
uh
yes representative cornell will do that
okay uh we're going to try and get the
the
minority and majority reports done today
so that we can get those to
jennifer four we will be uh
including um more bills to do today
so represent cornell um
can you please start writing
what what time do what time does it have
to be in
we've been told that bills that are
going to go forward that we acted upon
uh absolutely all the early bills but we
have other bills which we've acted upon
as well
need to be prepared and available for
the
administrative assistant by 11 o'clock
or 11 30 at the latest will
electronically you know do it
electronically
to to uh myself okay goodbye
[Music]
the same thing is applicable to
representative you need to get something
done
likewise um and that will be
the case hopefully uh for
just as we go forward here
if we run out of time then we run out of
time i understand this so we're going to
go into
hb1 10 right now that's the distribution
of adequacy grants
and uh i'd love to represent leon for
a promotion please thank you mr chair i
would like to move off to pass on house
bill
110. okay is there a second
second representative makes that a
second so we have a motion on
on the table here for uh
hb 110 distribution of adequacy grants
uh as
ought to pass made by uh representative
leon
and second by referendum president leon
do you have
any comments uh thank you mr chair
uh hb 110 in providing the
funding to the to the municipalities
rather than first to the school
districts
um in our discussions with the
department of education this will be you
know there should be no more than a half
day difference in time frame
and this will give clarity to the
municipalities in order to make sure
that they
understand exactly what is heading to
these school districts there are already
other monies that go through the
municipalities
and i i believe that this is a good bill
that for good clarification and good
transparency thank you
thank you very much uh representative do
you have any comments yeah just to
follow up thank you mr uh
do your the town or the municipality's
tax collector flex
all the other taxes going to
town and the school district so
this is a way for the tax collector to
know how much money
there is and how much money to then
distribute to the school
on a timely manner so yeah this
uh both cases is not a problem but in
some cases it seems to be a problem
so let's move forward with it
open to discussion from the committee at
thank you mr chair um i just want to
reiterate what uh the superintendent for
kearsarge said
um with any kind of regional district
with multiple towns
that means that the paperwork and the
transfer
is not just really easy it's done times
seven towns in the
in the kearsarge district um that's
that's 14
more times and in the past we have had
issues and i know other regional
districts have
issues with towns who have not
paid their portion of the school tax
in a timely manner for one reason or
another
and i think this just exacerbates that
problem
um i i see the the
process working well right now i really
think this is a kind of a bill looking
for a problem
and uh it's going to create more
bureaucracy and more paperwork so uh i'm
opposed to this bill
uh yes represent luna thank you thank
you mr chair
yeah um the um we did hear quite a bit
of testimony
uh on this but uh but but nothing
in the in the affirmative from from
from anybody involved in the in the
actual transaction
uh on either side of the transaction
either from the school district side or
from the municipal association side
we also didn't hear any evidence at all
that there was any credible problem
and any evidence from the department of
education that there's any credible
problem
to be solved by house bill 110 but we
certainly did hear
of um of problems that um
or just additional effort that's uh
that's going to have to be
born on the part of the school district
as a result of this so
so i you know i i i would not support
uh this bill thank you further further
comments represent woodcock
i think you get a brief one
representative thank you um on the bill
and the hearing
one of the things one of the things is
not true what i just heard now
all money doesn't necessarily go to the
tax collector
federal grants go to the go to the doe
and does some of the school department
so they all don't go there this is this
is a duplication
for many systems to do it twice to get
it out there so it really has
it has no usefulness it doesn't do
anything except made one more
layer and one more time of difficulty
thank you
thank you further representation
thank you uh chairman
um as a member sitting member of the
alderman board in the city of manchester
i don't want it they can have it
in the school department that's where it
belongs
i don't want to have to go through that
that's
uh we have enough uh
it's been it works well in manchester
and i'd like to leave it alone
not seeing any hands up okay reps i
wouldn't pop your hand is still off the
set
oh i'm this thing's killing me today
sorry
i apologize twice but everything okay we
understand
technology um thank you very much
uh not seeing any uh madame clark would
you call the role please
yes this is about to pass on house bill
110. representative cordelli
yes representative phone yes
representative allard
yes representative lakes yes
representative moffat
yes representative notter yes
representative andres
yes representative ford yes
representative lyon yes representative
saudi
yes i'm standing miler
it says well no no representative sean
no representative cornell no
i'm saying tanner no representative
ellison
no i'm senator mullen no
representative blake no i'm saying
woodcock
okay so uh this bill uh
will be of course placed on the regular
agenda hb110
passes eleven or nine will there be a
minority report i'm sure yes uh
representative tanner will do that
report directing vlad
thank you and
then we will have uh representative leon
you
okay moving on to the next bill that i
discussed earlier today hb 442
this is relative to penalties for
failure to report to the department of
education
so we have a
a motion made by uh resident cordelia to
move the amendment
0 3 8 3 h
what's that okay 0 3 8 3 h is there a
second
second represent allard seconds out of
motion
okay uh represent cordelia
thank you chairman um
i think everyone should have received an
email this morning with this amendment
that
might have gotten caught in affiliate 4
hcs was
mailing them out so i was not sure so i
sent it out
basically the amendment um is based on
discussions with the department of
education
uh who originally requested this bill uh
because of
problems with a just a handful that's
that of
schools or charter schools not providing
information
as required and this amendment
clarifies really a
miss misunderstanding
phrasing in the original bill
and the intention was not to require
private schools to submit reports
or tax for teacher salary information
that applies really just to public and
chartered public schools so
uh paragraph 1a
was added and
the teacher salary report was stricken
from 1 and 2 clarifies that it
is just the public and charter schools
that are to submit the
average teachers salary support so that
yes thank you um all right is there a
further discussion on the amendment
zero three eight three h
yes represent uh mylar yeah i just uh
represent cordelia why is
why is the information needed on this i
mean where is this
is this coming from a request from the
department that they want this
information or
uh yes representative just to try to
understand that it is a what is the
genesis for the amendment or are you
talking
like the whole bill yes
i have represented cardinality thank you
uh thank you for the question
uh yes this uh really uh originated
with uh discussions with the department
uh they contacted me
um about problems that they have had
i believe that there was recently a
charter school
that
turned in their charter based on
problems
found there and that is i believe one of
the instances where
they have been unable to get information
as required by the department from that
charter school
some teeth were needed in the statutes
to require the public and chartered
public schools
and in some cases non-public schools to
supply the information to the department
because in some cases that is also
federally required
information that has to be gathered by
the state agency
so they felt it was important to give
the department some clout in terms of
um
i'm not seeing any questions or comments
so you will move ahead with the
amendment would you please call the roll
yes this is the ought to pass on
amendment 0 3 8
3 h representative cordelli
yes representative boehm
yes representative allard yes
representative lakes
yes representative yes representative
yes representative ford
yes representative leon
yes representative soti yes
representative miler yes represent blue
now
yes representative shaw yes
representative cornell
yes representative tanner yes
representative ellison yes let's dan
mullen
yes dave lay yes
so now i'd like to recognize uh
represent
cordelia for a motion placement yes
thank you
chairman i would like to move uh my pass
is amended on
okay we have a motion on the table right
now to approve
uh this bill as amended with zero
three eight three h represent cordelia
do you care to speak to
your motion i think i have said all of
it
was required jake thank you our
representatives do you have anything to
say
are you good i'm good further discussion
from the committee not seeing any hands
uh would you please are you ready all
right
uh adam clark would you please call the
roll nope
mr chair all right mr chair
did you have your hand up yeah just
before we uh move
i i don't think it's uh inappropriate
miss davis is um in the queue here
is listening to this is there a need to
to
have her come in and basically indicate
that whether or not this is
needed it's a response to the question i
had representative cordelia on whether
or not
the doughy the doe needs this
information would it be appropriate
to have her at least comment on that i
have no objections to that request if
ms davis is willing to communicate with
us
she has her hand up right now i can
promote her representative lad
you just said jen okay
thank you um caitlin can you hear us
i'll take just a second
morning good morning um just just so you
know i was
in another meeting and i heard my name
and i came back over this so i missed
some of the preliminary conversation
um so um but i'm here um and i assume
we're still talking about hb442
that is correct right um so the
department actually did
reach out to representative cordelli um
in the beginning of the year
actually um the history of this bill is
um we had originally worked with senator
khan
last year to get this bill sponsored um
and then unfortunately with
everything that happened with kovan 19
and the delay in the legislative session
last year the bill
was tabled and we did not have a
resolution that the department needed
um so we then reached out to
representative cordelli over the summer
um and asked if he would sponsor this
legislation on behalf of the department
um this bill currently so our goal with
this bill was never to expand any
reporting requirements
um it was just to give the department a
little bit of teeth for some of the
reporting requirements
that are already in law that we have
that that same
kind of teeth that we have for district
public schools to expand those same
teeth to either
non-public schools or charter schools so
it is a little bit different in the
sense that for
a right now if a school district
fails to provide a regular district
public school district fails to
provide reporting the department of
education does have the authority to
withhold
various funding payments either federal
and or state
until those reporting requirements are
submitted to the department
but we do not have that same authority
over charter schools
and or non-public schools with
non-public schools
we do not provide them any funding so we
wouldn't have the authority to
hold any payments but we could ask the
state board of education
um to potentially
revoke their approval if they fail to
report more than two years in a row
some of the reporting requirements that
we're talking about are general
statistic information meaning enrollment
information
or health and safety this emergency
operation plans which are already
required
to be submitted in state law and then
for
charter schools we asked for
either the author the ability to ask the
state board of education to revoke the
charter
or to hold payments in the case that we
are making payments
so for example we have a charter school
that
is operating and has not had an audit
that's required
already in state law um we
we now if this legislation passes we'll
have the authority to
not pay them any more state funding
until the audit has
been um done so
thank you very much are there questions
of the department
i just i i even though we've uh voted on
this representative vlad
caitlyn i'm assuming that this uh the
amendment that we've already
just passed strengthens the uh original
bill that was
uh purported so yeah so the amendment um
was
it was the original language was a
little bit confusing
um so it just it
the um the non-public school folks had
kind of reached out and said
they their interpretation was it was
requiring them to submit other reports
that they were not required to
submit um so the amendment clarified
that no
we were just we're going to require them
to submit everything that's currently
in law um and there's just a little bit
of teeth for the department to do that
so that the amendment was just kind of
pulling the non-public peace out and
just clarifying that further
thank you very much thank you very much
caitlin further
questions for the department thank you
very much caitlin have a great day
thank you just to add a few comments
here
uh for those and i think reps and milo
you may have been a part of this and
aware of it but
remember when we had the 30 million
dollars for the infrastructure
monies for the safety security and
connectivity
in schools and a director plumber at
that time for homeland security and we
were looking at this
and it was brought to our attention that
a number of school districts
had not gotten their emergency
management plans in correct but we put
it to them and said you want to get the
money from this pot
you're going to have to get these done
bam those things came in to us
like greased lightning and we got all
that reporting done
i think it's incumbent on us to try and
support the department here
to ensure that reporting is
timely especially regarding someone's
federal grant money
so they could be holding up uh the whole
application or they could be holding up
you know
the new revenues coming in so
i think there is definitely some merit
behind this
i don't know anymore but are there any
other comments
you're not hearing any uh are seeing any
uh around the table here
uh madame cleric all right here be
prepared thank you very much
uh this is ought to pass as amended on
house bill 442.
representative cordelli yes
representative bone
yes representative allen yes
representative lakes
yes representative moffat yes
representative notter
yes representative andres yes
representative ford
yes representative leon yes
representative soti yes representative
miller
yes representative bluno yes
representative shaw yes representative
cornell
yes representative tanner yes
representative ellison representative
mullin
yes yes
excellent woodcock yes i'm saying vlad
yes 20 consent
yes and did i hear a yes somewhere
yes okay thank you um i don't see any
objections so
i'm consent this uh gets us through
where i
i plan to get going today as i mentioned
the front side
of our over our session starting
i'd like to remind representative
cornell representative moffatt
represent tanner representative land
no no not represent tanner represent
cordelia these reports
need to be gotten as soon as you can
would you please when you send them in i
don't know if you have
uh jennifer force
email address if not send them to me and
i will board them on the jets she does
review them
they go to the administrative committee
of the minister
administrative assistant then on over to
paul paul smith uh so i think we
finished a very timely manner and i
appreciate everybody's support today
um and i look forward to continuing our
conversations on tuesday next week i
think we have a room schedule for
existing next week
uh we have a number of uh other bills
which are on the dock and
i don't think they've been released yet
um
however uh they should be out in the
calendar sometime later today
so are any for further or departing
yes thank you uh mr chair um
so just to be clear we're meeting
tuesday with us
the uh full sessions on wednesday and
thursday is that correct
yes we are because unfortunately we're
on a committee that has
a high number high volume of bills
some committee has just about done their
bills
on their bills we have well over 50
and uh of course when a cent starts
piling in on us too
when crossover occurs so we have to
concentrate on those remaining bills
right now
and i will be talking to represent milo
try and start coordinating some of this
however we we do have a number of bills
we've got to address i mentioned the
school food waste program
private rights of action um
school contracts with uh independence
[Music]
we have several bills dealing with
menstrual products
criminal history records check annual
gifted survey
emergency meetings uh these type of
bills and it just goes down the list we
got a whole slack of these
and we're just going to start waiting
through them i just wanted to double
check thank you
welcome so i wish everybody had a
blessed weekend and uh
we can get some sleep
thank you very much everybody have a
good good happy life